hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master foreign auto ya head Queens
gambit accepted earlier against him so I
want to avoid it this time get some
variety in and that's a pretty good line
for Blackmon 96 something that I also
recommend recommend to play 22 black
players as a good alternative against
you three um yeah okay can go away five
actually not sure this is a good move
water a five yeah hmm doesn't look right
here
yeah I wonder actually if he goes a
forearm if I can sacrifice the Queen
it's probably a bit to be too fantastic
ride hard to believe that this should
work I go see five I think the SES be
six ideas analyze this quite a while ago
and I always felt that black is ok and
ok anyway
yeah I thought be six I mean it can also
maybe just castle and after I captured
twice on be four he goes b6 but
something like that he should play out
b6 immediately this is whatever thinking
okay what are you thinking of mr. fari
not ah yeah this one that's it's
certainly possible and there will be six
baby no you just place the pawn down hmm
ok well I certainly don't have the best
coordination ever special belt
especially the night damn that looks
pretty awful yo where'd you go some be4
be good if I get in a pawn support
and you try to reroute that night going
rugby aid now I guess no hook a five
that's a somewhat weird looking move out
k yeah let's let's just keep it keep
everything here and then move the green
next I cannot go before that easily as a
3s uncovered 95 he can take on c5 it's
also not great hmm now I'm not easy to
play them still okay let's go back them
the queen is immensely are natural they
are won't be four it's not easy for him
to play the B porn as the Seaborn will
be weak
hmm I expected that but I thought that
this is not a bad regrouping putting the
night over to d3 then I'd really has a
long journey at night a 3 C 2 and so on
but it's not a bad square h 5 is a
mysterious move just go engine repair
night f4 and moving it again but well
attacking h5 is it's not easy for black
to to handle so this is idea some bishop
t phone yeah okay that's not the end of
the world
yes like a syntactic Bishop takes h4 or
something weird I should have just
played you three actually I had just you
three of course and then go from there
would have been much easier
and ok we'll see what is going what is
going to do wow just allows the
destruction of his straw of his bone
structure
Wow ok check it's the kind of movie that
ok I'm taking it yeah whatever you want
I have to take it um ok so where is the
check should I try to get some things
going myself he doesn't have that many
pieces and his roots are kind of kind of
off I want to actually take myself will
get three look at one so we'll get three
yeah shouldn't be bad
so this one cannot it's easy to attack
us take a screen down time working not
easy here
and threatening to take on III here no
net once it was time to think was too
long nitey to was the thing and then
root g 3 this is what i need to get
going did you get that green driven away
at the tech tree six sets a thing oak
tree for I will take Oh what watch I'm
very irritating check
check check check black forfeits on time
it was kind of kind of wacky at the end
okay Wow okay so let's see what happened
damn that was a bit game huh so around
him there are certainly better options
for for black like my piece coordination
yet is some yeah it's not looking
looking very good I was thinking
thinking this may be but maybe I'm too
quickly as possible I'm probably too
quick with this damn they're like am ok
when she went down and still I mean my
coordination is so weird maybe he has
enough the engine gives gives us is
completely ok for black oh look p5 is a
strong move for concrete reasons if I go
here and here that's 94 now k that that
gives him a very good position so I
should have avoided a through him Andrew
and suggests this with about equal play
0 something zero zero point three four
one right it's not so it's a bit of a
tricky position you still feel I think
probably if you are black your fear
worried with the porn down on the other
hand white doesn't like its position
either because it's so
yeah so uh pneumonias rugby 54 strong
okay I went away to instill Luke a force
given as good black by the computer with
p6 to come with pressure now I mean I
was I was pretty positive that yes
compensation this okay I'm happy about
this development that I can activate
this h5 that's a weird move ok and now
h4 is okay and now I should just play
III I think and make this more solid go
go for go for this and ask him about
that pawn and now it got extremely wacky
Bishop g6 yeah okay I felt I needed to
take you 35 yeah took it certainly
alternatives here but it makes some
sense to to open the position and now
night have to wear this is probably
something that should have could have
been prevented the engine stopped fish
wants to do this I mean I'm still this
porn up which is nice to have but very
weird position this looks very weak but
I cannot attack it at the moment
especially the 90s shielding and if i
take it you know this is for example of
line that the computer gives and here
black is probably okay i mean he has got
this coming no check
and now I've got extremely extremely
lucky stockfish things I'm essentially
winning but it's still not not easy at
all or with no time which is free there
was a good idea and yeah he gave away
even more material even though the
position was was lucky enough to
probably have at some point where he had
something I have had that kind of hunch
check yeah rue cage one is made her cage
one now is made in a in a couple of
moves yeah King king g 2 is plus 8 plus
9 but Jack he has root g one not this
one this is a draw funny enough this is
this not ever this is a draw with Rugare
three made oh wow that would have been
would have been crazy i probably would
have done that and then we have the this
is a media Queen the Queen where's the
main I'm not even seeing the threat here
what is the bait exactly a queen h3 of
course the the night is pinned this is
the thing the night is pinned oh my
goodness nature's checkmate which is
checkmate Wow stuff okay thanks for
watching